hi I'm Erik Bosse and Rick and Morty
season three is now complete but a lot
of you have been hitting us up with some
lingering questions you still have now
what I love about Rick and Morty is that
it does its own thing and it doesn't cow
too much to the demands of its viewers
but yeah that often leaves us one
anymore debating what's really going on
here so let's quickly run through all
these unresolved mysteries and arm
ourselves for the next can't harm in a
Justin roiland live Q&A first question
what happened with the season finale
like why did season 3 end with a
relatively more grounded episode like
the Richter II and more to date and not
one of the more climactic game-changer
episodes with a dark cliffhanger like
the evil Morty Citadel episode I think a
lot of fans expectation was that season
3 would follow the tradition of seasons
1 & 2 and then with some wild cameo
filled episode where time gets frozen or
lots of people die or Rick gets
incarcerated but as I explained in my
breakdown videos season 3 couldn't in
that way with Rick taking charge of the
family at the start of the season pretty
much every episode broke the rules it
was honestly reaching a point where
nothing for any of the characters had
any emotional stakes anymore it felt
like the show was kind of painting
itself in a corner so in order to
survive the show needed to restore
itself to its status quo Jerry had to
return to the family Rick had to lose
his leadership and become the crazy
grandpa outsider that he was always
meant to be Beth and Morty needed to
rein him in and tell him off that way
season 4 can be in Beth's words in many
ways things will be like season 1 but
more streamlined and as great as episode
7 the Rick lantus mix-up was at the end
of the day that was a side adventure not
a season-ending installment that closed
out a lot of these emotional arcs but
that does bring us to our next question
why did the show bring back evil Morty I
think our expectation was that evil
Morty was going to be this series game
changer big bad and that he was actually
gonna be the president that Rick faced
off against in the finale but that's not
the kind of show Rick and Morty is it's
not so much a long game plot driven
cereal with overarching villains like
Game of Thrones or Breaking Bad it's a
sitcom anthology with series long
emotional arcs for its characters so I
think they brought back evil Morty for
two reasons one to fulfill the wishes of
fans who have been speculating about the
villain since season 1 admittedly that
eye patch moment was a pretty awesome
cliffhanger so it makes sense that the
writers would
to play with this element at some point
again but secondly and I talked about
this my breakdown the events of the
Citadel reflect on a large scale the
relationship between our Rick and Morty
Rick's routine cruelty toward Morty and
toward himself creates conditions that
bring out the darkest side of Morty so
the show cleverly used this side
adventure political cautionary tale to
warn us the dangers that our Rick and
Morty are headed toward so sure I think
evil Morty will come back in some form
on the show in the future but remember
this isn't his show I really don't think
we would like that show and honestly I
secretly think we'd be disappointed if
evil Morty returned for a big battle in
the season finale because then what
where do you go from that think about it
at least now the show has this ace and a
whole side character to surprise us with
whenever they want actually predict the
show will use evil Morty as a bizarre Oh
Morty or more accurately a Lex Luthor
Morty showing our Morty how successful
he could be if he just gave in to his
darker tendencies and his hatred of Rick
okay now before I get to the next
question I want to quickly thank the
sponsor of this video Vikings war of
clans we couldn't do without them
Vikings war of clans is an amazing
mobile game where people from all over
the world pick a side in these huge epic
battles between eastern and western
coalition's and destroy each other
seriously I just played this for a few
minutes and I'm already addicted to it
it's like those old PC strategy games in
the 90s and 2000's that I'm sure you'll
remember but now it's on mobile and a
new massive battle is coming this month
so get on board actually come find me in
the game I'm new rockstars underscore
Eric we can play together so support our
channel and download Vikings from the
links below and get our special bonus of
200 gold for a fast and successful start
okay next question you guys asked about
is Beth a clone now we actually made a
separate video about this but since then
the season finale gave us a few new
insights first Rick seems pretty coy
when Beth asks him over the phone enough
to cause pet to lose it later when Beth
talks to Jerry she concludes that she
probably is a clone because despite
having a memory of hating Jerry her
present feeling is love she's literally
a different person yet when Rick shows
up with a gun to the cabin he
reveals that it wasn't to kill off a
clone of his daughter that she's his
real daughter and the gun was actually
for Jerry and then the episode ends
laughing off this ambiguity maybe you
are a clown not like Rick would tell us
now to be clear this is what the show
wants us to take away from this it
doesn't matter whether Beth is a clone
or not that said I do think Rick was
lying when he dropped a gun and claimed
it was for Jerry in my opinion he came
there to kill clone Beth for becoming
self-aware and turning the family
against him but I think the image of his
daughter as a loving mother defending
her family moved Rick into seeing
himself as the threat to the family and
and conceding that would explain his
tongue biting frustration in the final
shot also I just liked the idea of the
original Beth a cynical evil Beth
exploring the multiverse and returning
to the show to bring out the worst in
Rick kind of like Tammy to with Ron
Swanson and Parks and Rec - all the sex
because that would be weird and speaking
of evil Tammy's what happened with Tammy
and Phoenix person now the post-credits
scene of the season three premiere
seemed to imply that they would be a
major threat to Rick and Morty but again
I think if we've learned one lesson from
the return of evil Morty this show
places humor over long game narrative a
ridiculous post-credit cliffhanger can
just be a joke sometimes a parody of
these sequel teasing stingers after
superhero movies so really I think we
should look at the resurrection of
birdperson as Phoenix person the same
way we did Ice T's origin story with the
numeric ons or Jaguar rescuing Rick and
Morty from concerto like maybe these
characters will come back but we
shouldn't read too much into how they're
changing the world of the show okay
final question some of you guys were
asking about why won't Rick and Morty do
a time-travel episode after three
seasons the show is delved into dozens
of popular sci-fi concepts but never
time-travel why so even though the
characters Rick and Morty were adapted
from roylene's animated shorts doc and
Marty a loose parody of Back to the
Future Roland and Harmon have made a
rule for themselves to never bring
time-travel into this world the reason
they felt was that time-travel has
already been explored exhaustively in
pop culture I mean time travel even came
up in things that aren't the matically
about time travel like Harry Potter Game
of Thrones
lost too many superhero movies and in
early 2002 I'm calm I'm sure you
all seen Kate and Leopold actually the
time travel in that movie was pretty
cool so instead Rolen and Harmon have
shelved time-travel I mean literally in
the background the garage every episode
Rick's box of time-travel stuff sits on
the Shelf unused like Christmas
decorations they are teasing us saying
oh we know time travels a thing and
we're not interested that's why any time
on the show time travel could be a thing
they go to awkward lengths to explain it
away season threes the ABCs of Beth
ended with Rick explaining his
impossibly quick pizza delivery by the
way that wasn't time travel there were
just a couple pizzas on the counter I
grabbed him meanwhile the show instead
focuses on alternate timelines and
realities moving laterally across them
but never forward or backward with in
any of those timelines do you think Rick
and Morty will ever do an origin story
for evil Morty what do you think his
origin is let me know what other
lingering questions or theories you have
in the comments below or hit me up on
Twitter at da Voss or follow new rock
stars at new rock stars for updates on
our videos like and share this video and
subscribe to new rock stars for all of
our Rick and Morty videos and be sure to
check out our breakdown to the finale in
the past season 3 episodes alright
thanks for watching bye